(Rires)
J'écrivais les gros titres.
Mon préféré, c'est :
« Un cerf m'a piétiné la gorge, et la presse a piétiné ma vie privée. »
Ce fut le titre le plus lu sur le site BBC News ce jour-là.
Cela m'amusait.
Au bout de ma semaine dans les médias,
J'ai utilisé cette nouvelle voix et plateforme
pour diffuser un message d'amour et de gentillesse.
Lorsque, au début, j'avais ressenti cette haine et cette colère
contre les journalistes,
il a fallu que je reconnaisse mes propres préjugés à leur égard.
Je les ai rencontrés, je leur ai parlé
sans porter de jugement.
Il a fallu que j'accepte de les comprendre.
En retour, ils ont commencé à me comprendre.
Six mois plus tard, ils m'ont demandé de rejoindre
un comité qui réglemente la presse.
Plusieurs fois par an, je bois du thé et je trempe des biscuits
avec, par exemple, Paul Dacre, éditeur du Daily Mail, qui me dit :
« Kate, comment se sont passés ces derniers mois ? »
Je respecte ces gens.
Je fais partie des trois membres du public
à prendre place à cette table --
pas parce que suis différente,
mais parce ma voix compte, comme celle de tout le monde.
L'ironie,
c'est qu'on me demande parfois de visiter les imprimeries
de cette industrie sur le déclin,
car certains pensent que
la technologie dont j'ai parlé ici sur TED, mes publications interactives,
pourraient les sauver.
Méfiez-vous donc de vos préjugés,
et faites de vos ennemis des alliés.
Merci
(Applaudissements)